[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24
octubre es el mes rosa dedicado a la
lucha contra el cáncer de mama que
afecta principalmente a mujeres de
cualquier edad después de la pubertad y
en todos los países del mundo el riesgo
se eleva con la edad en 2020 en todo el
planeta fueron diagnosticadas 2,3
millones de mujeres y
685.000 perdieron la vida pero para el
final del año 78 millones que lo
padecían hace 5 años seguían con vida
aunque el tratamiento puede llegar a ser
muy eficaces y hay detección temprana
este es el cáncer de mayor prevalencia
en el mundo y el más incapacitante en
funciones de los años de vida de las
pacientes
y ahora los datos sobre la detección
temprana y el tratamiento son claves
para superar la enfermedad los países
exitosos en sus esfuerzos por reducir la
mortalidad han logrado una reducción
anual entre el 2% y el 4% si este
trabajo fuera constante alrededor del
mundo y si se mantuviera un 2,5 por
ciento sostenido entre el 2020 y el 2040
se evitarían 25 millones de muertes
veamos
el cáncer de mama es el más común cerca
de una de cada doce mujeres lo sufrirán
a lo largo de su vida y es por ello la
principal causa de mortalidad femenina
por cáncer la mayoría de los casos y de
los decesos suceden en países de
ingresos bajos y medios por ejemplo
américa latina registró 100.000
fallecimientos en 2020 mientras que hay
una importante diferencia con naciones
desarrolladas donde la supervivencia a 5
años pasa del 90% ya que hay más
detección temprana pero en general este
padecimiento poco discrimina la mitad de
las ocurrencias en el mundo carecen de
un factor de riesgo identificable más
allá de haber nacido mujer o superar los
40 años de edad lo que sí está
demostrado según cita la organización
mundial de la salud es que la obesidad
el consumo de alcohol y tabaco los
antecedentes familiares la exposición a
radiación y el historial reproductivo
pueden aumentar el riesgo
lamentablemente aún controlando esos
indicadores la posibilidad de padecer
cáncer de mama tan sólo se reduce un 30%
los hombres también pueden ser pacientes
pero su incidencia está solo entre el
0.5 y el por ciento la conversación
sobre el tema es con bolivia bocaranda
presidenta de senosayuda asociaciones
sin fines de lucro y dedicada a la lucha
contra el cáncer de mama en venezuela
bolivia además es sobreviviente
bienvenida a ellos hoy y quiero
preguntarle cuál es la situación en
américa latina porque si te diagnostican
con cáncer de mama en esta región del
mundo hay más riesgo de morir que en
otras partes del planeta
bueno primero muchas gracias por
es donde es muy parecida a la mediana
tina nosotras no tenemos una cultura
preventiva generalmente vamos al médico
ya cuando tenemos algún síntoma algún
signo de alarma o nos sentimos algo en
la mama y en ese momento puede ser te
amo está la diferencia como los dijeron
adn antes de tu programa pues es
asombrosa entre los países
industrializados los países del tercer
mundo y nuestra realidad y en venezuela
la situación se hace cada día más
caótica y es una situación en toda la
región y en todo el mundo pues lo que ha
sucedido con la pandemia e incluso en
los eeuu el número de mamografías que
durante todo el tiempo de la pandemia
disminuyó en un 20 por ciento lo cual
hace que estos retrasos puedan generar
mayores regresos en lo que es un
diagnóstico en una pesquisa
en octubre hacemos todos los esfuerzos
por las pesquisas a tiempo y bueno es el
mes del año en donde hacemos mayor
énfasis en realidad el llamado es a las
mujeres a que se cuiden siempre para que
siempre estén pendientes de su mamá y a
cualquier signo de alarma inmediatamente
atender a los médicos especiales
que tenemos que ser responsables con
nuestro cuerpo y estarnos revisando
constantemente sin embargo hay una
realidad y es que hay muchísima censura
alrededor de la teta y de los pezones y
demostrar las mamas femeninas usted cree
que esa censura que existe en general en
los medios de comunicación por ejemplo
contribuye a que no nos conozcamos ya
que no nos hagamos el autoexamen oa que
nos demoremos más por lo tanto en
detectar el cáncer
yo creo que al revés yo creo que los
medios de comunicación han tenido un rol
predominante en todo este tema de sacar
el cáncer de mama
del closet como lo digo yo cuando yo fui
diagnosticada hace 22 años pues apenas
se venían algunos artículos de los
periódicos impresos bien los en la
televisión sobre el cáncer de mama hubo
una campaña que marcó un hito
comunicacional en venezuela que fue una
campaña de la sociedad cancerosas y a
partir de ese momento pues empezamos con
los testimonios y darle cara al cáncer y
acabar con ese mito de que cáncer es
igual a muerte si hay un diagnóstico
precoz o si hay una atención médica a
quien josé no puede los gratos
protocolos de prevención de tratamiento
del canal terapia y de quimioterapia los
porcentajes de sobrevivencia son
alarmantes yo soy un ejemplo de esto
hace 22 años diagnosticada uno y hago la
mención especial de que fue una cumbre
porque yo venía de los eeuu bombardeadas
por todos lados que si eres mayor de 40
años la tomografía y me fui a hacer una
mamografía a los 40 años y a los 46 pues
el hallazgo y ya ya el hecho desde los
medios de comunicación traten el tema
pues ayuda a romper junto a esos mitos
in august de técnicos en los balances
bueno son diversos los tratamientos que
existen para el cáncer de mama uno de
ellos es la extracción preventiva de las
mamas quisiera que nos hablara un poco
de este procedimiento cómo se llega a él
y sobre todo cómo podría prevenir un
futuro cáncer
bueno hay que estar este tipo de canción
y para no todo no para no todos los
cánceres pues en la extracción en la es
la práctica más adecuada fue un caso muy
conocido el de angelina jolie iguales
venezuela tuvimos a nuestra querida eva
duarte fue misma miss venezuela en el
mundo y que falleció muy joven
estos son pipas de sus habitantes
responden a una carga genética
determinada y por lo tanto le hacen esa
salvedad de hacerle una mastectomía
radical pero no en todos los casos no de
todos los cáncer hay que hacer
mastectomía radical yo como éste con una
mastectomía
parcial como fue en mi caso con unos
niveles de sobrevivencia de 22 años pues
es muchísimo y además con muy buena
calidad de vida yo creo que la decisión
la excitación de la mamá con una
mastectomía radical tiene que ir de
acuerdo a la historia clínica de cada
uno de los pacientes
hablemos acerca de la maternidad y la
lactancia si bien el ser madre
tardíamente podría convertirse en un
factor de riesgo para el cáncer de mama
la lactancia extendida podría ayudar a
prevenir este mal
y así él ha comprobado que la lactancia
una garantía como un factor que
disminuye las posibilidades de tener
cáncer de mama por lo tanto es
importantísimo que las mujeres
practiquen la lactancia
además de todos los beneficios que eso
genera ponerte de equipo en la
comunicación entre el bebé
y hay otro tema también bolivia de que
usted seguramente tiene grandísima
claridad y es el acompañamiento que
necesitamos las mujeres después de
atravesar el proceso de un cáncer y en
muchos casos la pérdida de uno o de
ambos senos por qué es tan importante
continuar el proceso más allá del
tratamiento médico con la salud mental
de las mujeres
sí por eso nosotros tenemos dentro de la
fundación y es una copia de un programa
americano que lo practican todos los
hospitales oncológicos en los estados
unidos en inglés sting wood luke better
que nosotros le pusimos el nombre a
través de en la fundación del programa
se nos miman de levantar el ánimo de
levantar la autoestima de la mujer que
está pasando con esa tratando aquí a
través del banco de pelucas de pronto
sitios sostenes pues se ayuda a que esta
mujer no se sienta esté completamente
mal durante todo su proceso y está
demostrado el sentirse bien pues ayuda a
que la recuperación sea mucho más rápido
igual que recibir apoyo psicológico
antes de ir a una quimioterapia
someterse a un tratamiento crea mejores
resultados en un futuro en todo el
tratamiento y también hay que hacer la
salvedad de no solamente a la paciente
sino también el cuidador está es el
cuidador también necesita el apoyo
psicológico de nuestra fundación en
venezuela vamos a poner no solamente en
la paciente sino también a ese familiar
a esa medida que le hace el
acompañamiento y que tiene a veces de
pasar de un hospital a otro hospital de
una farmacia otras farmacias pues
buscando un medicamento buscando
atención médica que no se consigue muy
fácil los internos
lamentablemente
bolivia la organización mundial de la
salud prevee que van a aumentar en 30%
en los próximos años los casos de cáncer
de seno aquí en américa latina' a qué se
debe esta predicción que se volvería muy
difícil y un problema de salud pública
aún mayor para la región
es por la última ocasión que tú has
hecho porque no se ha considerado el
tema dentro de la agenda de la política
junta si es la primera causa de muerte
oncológica
con países o la segunda causa de muerte
teniendo una mortalidad para elevar
desde 42 mil muertes debería ser
atendido como una como prioridad número
uno en la agenda de promoción y no está
siendo atendida como una insuficiencia
de hospitales de equipos calibrados y de
buena calidad la insuficiencia de la
infraestructura y mucho más bonita con
este tema de pandemia
en venezuela creo que la realidad muy
parecida en los otros países pues se les
digo a las pacientes con cáncer de mama
y otras enfermedades crónicas espérense
que ahorita vamos a estar atendiendo a
los pacientes con bobby y luego tendrán
el caso de las pacientes con cáncer de
mama el cáncer no puede esperar a que
hacer un protocolo con tiempo y en unos
plazos determinados y por eso es tan
importante cumplir con rigurosidad ese
tratamiento sino que viene después de
una operación de una radio y una quimio
maquilla de terapia hormonal el llamado
es a todos los gobiernos a que le den y
nos coloquen en donde está en prioridad
dentro de las agendas
de la política
y que así sea bolivia le agradezco mucho
sobre todo por toda la información que
nos entrega y que nos ayuda a hacer más
conciencia y a educar más sobre la
necesidad que tenemos de protegernos y
de proteger a nuestros seres queridos
gracias a ustedes y también a nuestros
televidentes recuerden que este y otros
programas lo pueden encontrar en
france24 punto com y nos vemos
próximamente en ella soy
[Música]